welcome to bananamores
new york's funniest comedy club i'm the
owner and proprietor
mitzi bananamore here at bananamores our
motto has always been you
gotta laugh also you gotta laugh i'm not
kidding you've gotta laugh or you've
gotta go to us
i'm kidding i mean i'm not but you know
hey
after this year we could all use a good
laugh am i right
2020 has really kicked us all in the
took us and the best cure for a tender
took us
is laughter but people don't even go out
to the comedy bonds and basements
anymore
because they can't i mean the worst
thing you could get at a comedy club was
a hacky joke about
airplane food and now
[Music]
but that's why i'm taking my business
digital and we want you
right up here on the world famous
bananamore stage we're booking the best
alan in town
or out of town or wherever you are
zooms in new york and las vegas and la
we're going digital anything can happen
we live in the future it's incredible
you'll get up on the stage
for one two three minutes or if you just
have a joke
great just be funny and if you're not
you'll get the light
and you do not want to be on the other
end of my light i'm kidding but i'm also
not
so i hope to see you here real soon on
the bananamore stage
until you get the light and then you
gotta go i'm serious
i'm kidding but i'm not it also burns
ps keep it semi-clean try to stay away
from politics and drugs that's what i
say
goes for more than a comedy club